the university of massachusetts at
amherst has suspended
three students over this photo of them
maskless at an off-campus party now
parents of at least two of those
students are fighting back
they're filing a class action lawsuit
against the school after it kicked the
students
out for their spring semester and
refused to refund their 16
thousand dollar tuition and while umass
says the students violated its cove
its coveted policies the parents say the
school let its national
championship hockey team hold a parade
with no social distancing
and some students even going maskless
you know kennedy let me start with you
here this seems a little harsh
one of these girls was a valedictorian
of her school former class president in
her high school
and they're just kicked out entirely no
grades no tuition
so they weren't just suspended because i
think it would have been appropriate if
they were out of school for a little bit
maybe given the warning they weren't
just suspended
they were not allowed to take their
final exams uh so that means that they
have to scrap the year and they have to
essentially reapply
for next year uh this will not be and
again you and emily obviously are both
lawyers but
as a parent all i would be doing is
scrubbing or searching
social media other students here to see
if anyone else was it any sort of a
gathering without
a mask and i'm sure you will find
hundreds of examples
so this should be a pretty clear case
for them
they have every right to be upset this
is everything that's wrong with academia
right now
and it is such an uneven application of
these rules
and frankly i love hockey but it's a
little sexist
governor huckabee look uh fox news
points out we don't know when this
picture was taken
uh therefore we don't know if they were
in the clear with cdc guidelines and
governor charlie baker's guidelines
saying if you're vaccinated you can be
outdoors
however we do know the hockey team they
were violating governor charlie baker's
executive order against parades and
festivals
i don't think either group should be
punished let me be clear but there does
seem to be a disparity here
well it's more than a disparity this is
insanity i mean these girls got in more
trouble for not wearing
a mask outdoors then they would have
gotten in trouble had they not worn
clothes outdoors and for them to lose an
entire year of college
is ridiculous come on i'm glad their
parents are suing i hope they win
and i hope they win a huge judgment and
that no college is this stupid again
emily to you on the class action lawsuit
what's the likelihood of success
they haven't filed yet so it remains to
be seen the crux of their argument but i
think
kennedy is correct in that it will be
the disparate application the university
hosted that parade
against their own violations and at the
time governor baker's
forbidden against federal festivals and
parades
um and also the sheer draconian nature
of this punishment
of that of that uh kicking them out and
keeping that sixteen thousand dollars
each and we know that umass amherst had
among the strictest cr
covid protocols this entire time and yet
they've been
levying interim suspensions not that
same impact so
remains to be seen when they actually
file but they have the support of their
state senator
barry feingold and he's on full
agreement with them
harris bring us home uh just real
quickly
i'm wondering you know a lot of
education experts say that we've already
lost
nine to 12 months of learning for
certain age groups
so to add on to that with another year
potentially for college students
is a huge penalty to pay in greater life
for a mistake that looks like it
took place in the time it took to take a
picture